foreign
comes from Drew in Austin he writes I
hear you guys on the show talk about
being quote house poor and not spending
more than 25 percent of your take-home
pay on your mortgage payment can you
explain more of what house porn means
and what's bad about it in today's real
estate market that is tough to do with
high home prices higher interest rates
Etc what is the harm of paying 30 to 35
percent if that's what it takes to get
into a house these days especially since
it is only going to appreciate in value
well this is interesting it's a good
question number one the idea of the
house appreciating value doesn't change
the numbers of you have this much income
and this much of your world is being
taken up by that house payment
and so that's what being house poor
comes down to you don't have enough
money left over to do all the other
things like fund college fund retirement
go on vacation upgrade the car cover the
emergencies and so being housebor just
means that you have too much of your
world wrapped up in that mortgage
payment and that's too many Americans
today
there's a reason that people have a car
payment if they have a 35 percent of
their income going to house payment they
don't have room in their budget to save
up and pay for a car so they go into
debt so house poor means I borrowed so
much on my house that I end up borrowing
on other things oh and my kids in the
future they'll have student loans
because I didn't save for their school
oh and anything I get ready to do that I
don't have room is George said
economists call the room in your budget
the margin in your budget your
disposable income the income you have
for saving and for investing and for
enjoying and if after your debt payments
you don't have any disposable income any
margin left any wiggle room left in your
budget you're going to end up in our
society going into debt and so Drew let
me tell you one other thing I appreciate
your call or your email in today's real
estate market it's tough to do with high
home prices higher interest rates that
is a phrase I have heard
since I went on the air in 1992.
every year someone says but Dave
I live in California and we don't use
math here
Dave I live in New York and math doesn't
count here because it's so expensive
that we don't have to follow
mathematical
facts we can just borrow and say oh it's
expensive to live here oh interest rates
are high and I want a house and so but
you're the the downstream result of that
is that that
you're going to find yourself lacking in
Investments
and lacking in kids college funds as
George said and lacking in money for
emergencies so everything that happens
in your life is a potential new debt
because you went so far in debt in the
name of getting a house because you
rationalized and said well the world has
never been like this well honey the
world has always been like this
I'm old and it's always been like this
house prices have when my parents bought
their first home in 1962.
12 000
250 big dollars you can't buy a used car
for that much these days three and a
quarter percent interest rate and you
know what they got 8 30.
my grandfather had a fit you're gonna be
in debt for 30. have you lost your
30-year mind
old people back then thought you were
sinning if you went that far in debt
well you're buying a coffin at that
point yeah 30 years a long time yeah
my parents right yeah but they sign up
for 30 years at 12 000 and man I mean my
first apartment rent was 235 a month
you can't even what you'd have to get
nine roommates to do that you can't
cross the threshold for that that's
unbelievable they won't even let you go
look at an apartment
you know but that but it didn't matter
in those days my pay was different
and guess what the overall the cost of
goods was different gasoline was a buck
26. okay when that rent was there so
it's all relative in Russia and ratios
and so
um not picking on you and giving you
know Boomer line here you just don't
understand youngin but you just don't
understand young and it's always been
this way
it's always been high yeah and you
always have to make a decision to say no
so later you can say yes live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else